[Music]
who the sexiest photo on my phone can I
chose it it's really I think it's sexy I
think it's beautiful
Chrissy Teigen reveals secrets from
inside her phone in a new video from
glamour no one ever sees my dad they see
so much of my mom but they don't know
that I'm very close with my dad they're
still my mom and dad are still out there
by the way everyone does my mom pretty
much lives with us at our house in Los
Angeles and but my dad comes by every
single day in that same issue Chrissy
penned a candid essay about her struggle
and a diagnosis with postpartum
depression admitting it was hard to get
out of bed or even eat after the birth
of her daughter Luna last April quote I
would go two days without a bite of food
and you know how big of a deal food is
for me after her essay was published
Chrissy took to Twitter pleading those
who approached her not to tiptoe around
her quote all of a sudden everyone's how
are you turns to how are you know what
I'm saying
you